and over to the tightest match of
champion showdown chess960 as
Petersfield there even the score in
quite the bra absolutely a thrilling
fight showing the four-time US Champion
against the eight-time Russian Champion
and right now the score is deadlocked at
even certainly an excellent match so far
Peter tell us your thoughts about the
day well I'm very happy with the outcome
I am not entirely sure if I play
particularly well but I think I'm in
plus 1 I will level definitely take +1
in the end of this day I think you know
it sounds funny to even say those words
but I think he car thoroughly out
preparing me today he had he had ideas
where I had like none frankly and I
think he got more promising positions
with white and had no problems with
black and but the games themselves were
I mean there were some dry games and but
the blue blitz game is very very
interesting and happy too happy to have
survived that because Knight takes e4 so
fast in this one but is there any I mean
we probably don't want to bring I yeah
because the previous the previous one
because I want to show you the scenario
of today but basically basically I and
there are two things there which are
very beautiful and it's a pity that I
can't show them one is one is not
beautiful one is basically when I played
this move Queen c8 if you remember when
I allowed Knight takes e5 and had to
find all those most to make a draw I
thought that takes e5 allows making
three a very nice beautiful mate in
three in the center of the board but
unfortunately midway through that
variation I was playing Queen takes a 4h
forecheck and Bishop takes h4 is a
reasonably simple reply to it which kind
of foils my plan of giving me two three
with checks and I had to kind of
scramble to find other ideas but instead
of all that mvl pointed out after the
game we kind of discussed it a little
bit and I I think I had absolutely
fantastic study like win
to do most prior to that but had I found
that on 30 seconds I think my career
would have been capped I mean I was like
you just don't make those moves on 30
seconds I think but yeah in this this
final game it was a mess and I mean I I
played this g7 g6 move which I thought
was very very beautiful instead of that
I think I have made in five was checks
which I didn't see which was which was
frankly slightly simpler and I got up
from the board and Sam Shanklin came up
to me and said just out of curiosity is
there anything wrong with rock H one
Queen t2 Queen e1 cringy one Queen h1
mate I didn't know so as I said I'm not
sure just how you know viewer this was
but it was it was a bit of a dogfight
and I'm happy to to have come out of
here today let me talk about bras we
don't think of them as pure just yeah
two heavyweights punching each other and
under the tension trying to find moves
how is the 960 situation as you said you
were so-called our prepared because your
opponent just had better ideas but how
does that change the calculus off these
brawls we don't see the selling in time
pressure you guys seem to be handling
the situations really well it that's
that's the one thing that kind of gives
me some hope because I was really
worried about the Blitz portion I felt
that I'm a dog against ícaro in in any
kind of a blitz much anyway but in
particular because I have zero
experience with delay and he has some
experience with delay
I felt that I will I will sort of I will
get a lot more worried in these
situations and this will be a problem
but I seem to be surviving somehow it
does get to me I get a lot more nervous
on let's say 20 seconds then I would
knowing its increment obviously this is
just you are a time Russian champion but
this is my first this is my first
tournament with this time control and
but as I said I mean I'm less worried
now I was a lot more worried two days
ago when we were speaking before the
start of the tournament and and one
thing I wanted to mention because I
don't know if the cameras are not
allowed I think upstairs between noon
and 1:00 right but there's a lot of
community work being done in the opening
theory in that hour oh we do we do have
our cameras your cameras mean
we rent and today was a you know
extremely good day for me because I got
to discuss chess with Gary and and it's
very difficult to describe just how how
good this makes me feel because it's
been such a long time since I sat down
at the board with Gary and just
discussed discuss something just just
related with him and it's just such a
pleasure for me to to be able to do that
we it feels like we did not get very
many things exactly right but that that
really is relevant because just just
sitting there for an hour you know
looking through options and discussing
positions and just talking chess with
him for for the first half of the day
that was um today's a good day firing a
very sparring story and you're inspiring
us with your play we look forward to
seeing you tomorrow thank you very much
thank you